Девушки отдыхают... Hallo Wien! Wien, was geht's? Hallo Florian! Oh, hallo! Hey, na? Hallo! Hey, Wien, was geht's? Wow! Wow! Hallo, hallo! Schön, dass ihr es machen konntet! Schön, dass ihr da seid! Yes! Yes! Love the energy! Meine Damen und Herren, es ist mir eine grosse Ehre, ihn ankündigen zu dürfen. Er ist heute hier, er hat es geschafft. Es ist Staffan Tietze! Und er ist auch hier, ihr hattet schon nicht mehr mit ihm gerechnet, aber er ist tatsächlich gekommen. Florentin Will! Dankeschön, ist sehr nett von euch. Dankeschön. Ich mag diese Geste, ich mag die so sehr, diese Faust. Die ist gut. Vor allem, ich habe mir gedacht, wenn man im Supermarkt irgendwo ansteht und man regt sich immer nur auf, wenn man die schlechte Schlange hat. Niemand macht den hier, wenn er die gute Schlange erwischt hat und schneller ist an der Kasse. Ja, wenn einer vor einem noch so sagt, so okay, ich hab's nicht sein, ich brauch doch keine Kondome, geht nochmal weg. Oder dahinter einfach so, yes, aber schneller. Man freut sich zu selten über gute Dinge, die passieren. Wenn du im Stau oft in der richtigen Spur bist, kennt ihr hier Stau in Österreich, ich weiß nicht, bei uns ein großes Problem, dann müsste man so an den Leuten vorbeifahren.
Ich glaube, es ist ein sehr guter Ratschlag für alle ausser dieser Person da hinten, die kann das sehr, sehr gut, die hat sich gerade sehr, sehr gefreut.
Ja, gerade hat jemand die Handy-Diode, das finde ich eigentlich ganz geil, aber man macht immer so, und niemand jubelt auch so, ausser bei Shows, wo man ist, also, ne, aber gerade hat jemand beide Handy so in die Höhe gerissen er will so wenn man so rollercoaster teicung gespielt hat war ja nicht ganz gut props es ist die beste gewinnerpose ich meine sterren du bist ein mensch der existiert viel in seinem eigenen kopf du stellst dir viele dinge vor weil du auch in deinem echten leben nicht so also noch nicht aber bald und hast du schon eine position die über die mann ja also, weil du erzählst oft so, ja, irgendwann habe ich meinen Sesamgarten und so und dann so, du hast einfach viele gute Ideen in deinem Kopf so und du bist, das war eine gute Idee mit dem Sesam, das war auch eine geile Idee, ja, gut, wusste niemand, dass Monen dann die beliebteste Form ist, ja, du hast sehr, sehr viel Geld verloren dadurch, aber konnte niemand mit rechnen, du dachtest, Sesam braucht man für alles, Ich wusste, es kommt eine Sache auf Brötchen, wird so richtig eine heiße Scheisse, aber das auf Sesam gesetzt. Und seitdem jedes Mal, wenn jemand beim Bäcker sagt, ich hätte gerne ein Sesambrötchen, mache ich Yes! Stefan Tietze, es ist Stefan Tietze, er freut sich heute darüber. Es tut uns sehr leid, Wien, aber wir haben beide, das Erste, was wir heute miteinander gesagt haben, war, fuck, ich habe so Rückenschmerzen und Florian so,, ich hau. Heute ist die Rückenfolge, also wir haben Rollatoren bereit hinter der Bühne, auch für Leute hier, wir sehen, das ist ein großes Problem, also wir merken, wir gehen langsam kaputt und wir zerfallen wahrscheinlich live auf dieser Bühne hier in der nächsten Stunde, also ihr könnt mitverfolgen, wie dieses Evolutionsbild langsam rückwärts so zurückgespult wird und wir am Ende wieder so auf den Boden kriechen. Das ist furchtbar. Wir haben am Ende wieder bei einer Massagesessel-Hotline anrufen von Folge 1. Genau. Da wir uns langsam höher zurückentwickeln. Und da müssen wir den Podcast beenden, so dann ist der Kreis einfach durch. Die müssen uns zurückrufen. Das stimmt, ja. Das stimmt eigentlich. Das stimmt! Es ist tatsächlich wahr, ich hatte vor ein paar Tagen nachts so harte Rückenschmerzen, dass ich nicht schlafen konnte. Und du liegst da und einfach nur, dann existierst einfach nur in Schmerz. Und dann habe ich mir um drei Uhr nachts, wenn man sich denkt, ich kann nicht mehr schlafen, um drei Uhr nachts habe ich mir den gesunder Rückentrainingsplan gekauft. Und habe dann drei Uhr nachts angefangen, dann irgendwie so die Übungen zu machen, wo auch mein Rücken gesagt hat, die Richtung ist gut, aber ein bisschen zu spät, mein Freund. Jetzt damit anfangen. Jetzt damit anfangen. Es ist wie, als ob du vor so einem abgebrannten Haus stehst mit so einem Gartenschlauch und noch versuchst, es zu löschen. Oder du fährst noch schnell zum Supermarkt und sagst, ich brauche Rauchmelder. Ja, ich brauche Rauchmelder. Ich brauche jetzt Rauchmelder, jetzt ist los. Dringend. Ja, also falls jemand gute Ideen hat gegen Rückenschmerzen. Aber was waren so deine Übungen? Jetzt mal ohne Scheiss, ich meine, wir sind hier unter uns.
Mach mal die Übungen vor, die du...
Also es ist dann...
Ne, das finde ich jetzt...
Ne, die Sache ist die...
Ne, wir können das gerne alle hier zusammen machen tatsächlich, weil im Grunde ist es sehr leicht.
Ich setze mich mal hin und dann können wir das alle mitmachen hier.
Wir machen es alle zusammen.
Ich bin auch einfach gespannt, wie das jetzt klingt.
Ob wir alle so... Jetzt hören wir ganz viele so ISG,
Isio-Sakralgelenk, habe ich gelernt. Ja. Es ist tatsächlich sehr sexuell, muss man tatsächlich sagen, glaube ich, hilft auch in anderen Belangen. Und alles, was ihr machen, müsst ihr jetzt euch mal alle sehr aufrecht hin. Und jetzt alles, was ihr tut. Ja, aber er zeigt auch, dass alle in so einer, er zeigt was ihr habt Haltung vorher waren, in so einer zurückgelehnten, ja ich habe hierfür gezeigt, so jetzt will ich top noch schon Haltung und dann sagt man, wir sind jetzt aufrecht, alle so ein bisschen ertappt auch. Ja und dann müsst ihr jetzt einfach nur euer Becken nach, du sitzt auch gar nicht gerade, ihr müsst euer Becken so nach hinten drücken, sodass ihr so ein Hohlkreuz bekommt. Einmal so Hohlkreuz. Also Hohlkreuz, also nach vorne kippen. Wollt ihr nicht? Ja, also das Becken muss nach hinten, so drückt es so in den Sitz rein und dann Becken nach vorne, sodass so eine kleine Krümmung entsteht. Oh, das tut weh, das ist das Schlimme bei mir. Und können wir das jetzt mal nur akustisch im ganzen Raum haben? So, jetzt machen wir hinten. Achtung, Ruhe bitte. Und nach vorne. Sehr gut. Und geht's euch besser? Geht's euch besser? Ihr seid wieder besser dran. Nee, nee, nee, warum stehst du schon auf? Wir machen das jetzt zehn Minuten lang. Genau, das ist nämlich auch das Ding. Ich habe mir diesen Trainingsplan dann runtergeladen und da stand dann, machen sie diese Übung so zehn Minuten lang. Und ich dachte mir selbst mit dieser Agonie an Schmerzen, er hat zweimal erreicht. Das ist schon einfach keine, selbst dann im schlimmsten Moment sage ich nicht, es geht weiter, du scheinst es wirklich nötig zu haben. Ich habe eine andere Übung gemacht, Achtung. So, jetzt mal alle aufstehen bitte. Ich glaube, die heisst Kamelkatze, bin mir aber nicht sicher. Kuhkatze kenne ich auch. Kuhkatze? Ja, ich glaube, es ist unterschiedlich. Das ist eher das, was Florentin sagt. Ja, so unterscheiden sich die verschiedenen Trainingsarten. Stark. Okay, hier ein ganz kleiner Gruß an unsere Podcast-Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer. Es gibt immer noch Merch zu kaufen im Shop. Stefan Tietze beugt sich gerade Katzen gleich, macht den Rücken krumm. Und ich würde sagen, das war ordentlich. Stark, ja. Nee, aber ich hatte so krasse Rückenschmerzen. Es ist mir passiert beim Sport tatsächlich, weil ich mich irgendwie eine schwere Sache hochgehoben habe von nur auf einer Seite. Und dann habe ich gemerkt, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott. Und dann konnte ich tatsächlich, es ist keine Übertreibung, macht man ja häufig im Podcast, komödiantisch übertreiben, aber und konnte dann nur noch so gehen. Ach Gott. Und dann habe ich geguckt, wo der nächste Orthopädin war und die war eine dreiviertel Stunde weg. Zwei Kilometer. Und das war mein Tempo halt und ich dachte mir, ich bin saueng, aber ich bin losgesportet in meinem Tempo und habe es dann zu ihr geschafft, weil die noch drei, vier Stunden auf hat. Dann hat sie mich aber noch fünf Minuten vor Ladenschluss, Praxisschluss, hat sie mir gesagt, ja, kannst du noch kurz ins Praxiszimmer kommen und dann hat sie mich entblockiert. Hat sie gesagt, ich weiss nicht, ob es so ein Trick ist von wegen ja, wir können jetzt nichts tun, um dir ein gutes Gefühl zu geben, mache ich dir so einen Verband. Irgendwas wird schon knacken, was dir das Gefühl gibt zu sagen, ja, das war's wohl. Aber die wollte wahrscheinlich auch schon so Feierabend machen, hat gesagt, komm, ich packe es, schau so aus dem Fenster und sieht so am Horizont nur diesen Stefan, so ganz langsam, da hat sich, ach, fuck, schon wieder kein Columbo für mich heute. Da hinten kommen sie schon wieder. Ja genau, aber so eine Reihe aus Menschen. Der erste geht so, der zweite. Aber da muss ich sagen, das wäre mir zu blöd. Ich finde es immer blöd, wenn Leute... Dann gehen so oben die Salosien runter. Aber das ist mir immer peinlich, wenn Leute verstehen, was ich machen will. So wenn ich im Supermarkt so eine Packung Toast und einen Toaster kaufe. Ja, ja. Das ist immer peinlich. Und deswegen würde ich auch, wenn ich zum Paläontologen, wie war das? Paläontologäontologen gehen würde, würde ich auch wirklich alles, meine ganze Kraft, bündeln in die letzte Treppe, um da möglichst sportlich nochmal hochzustiefeln, damit niemand sieht, warum ich da bin. Dass du, wenn du zum Zahnarzt gehst und dir so den Mund hältst, so ooooh. Ich habe mir gedacht, es ist zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben, dass die Schmerzen nicht verschwunden sind im Badezimmer. Das habe ich nämlich immer, dass ich im Badezimmer bin und man hört es auch weh zu tun. Ich denke mir, ich habe mich selbst da mit dem Imposter-Syndrom verbunden gefühlt, weil ich dachte, ich habe hier nichts verloren. Ich habe hier nichts verloren. Und da hat er die richtige Schmerzen und sagt mir, ich gehöre hierhin. Mein Leben hat wieder einen Sinn. Ich bin an einem richtigen Ort. Es ist auf medizinischer Ebene bluffen, zu sagen, ach wirklich, du tust weh, dann gehen wir jetzt mal zum Arzt.
Und dann sagt der Körper, ja okay, fakt ist noch nichts, scheiße.
Okay, okay, dann noch nicht, nee, keinen Husten mehr, zieh den Husten zurück, ich sag, egal, ciao.
Aber so, nee, dann gehen wir jetzt zum Arzt.
Schwierig.
Und dann musste ich aber meine Hose ausziehen.
Ja.
Ihr wisst nicht, wohin die Geschichte geht. Er hat ziemlich angefasst. Um meine Blockade zu lösen. Aber bin nicht verstanden. Ich habe dann aber einen Arzt, also einen Medizinstudenten, einen Freund gefragt, ob das okay ist, oder ob ich mich jetzt rückblickend angefasst fühlen darf. Aber es ist wohl völlig okay, dass man dafür die Hose ausziehen muss. Aber es ist spannend, weil wir haben ganz unterschiedliche Ansätze. Du bist vernünftigerweise zum Arzt gegangen, ich bin unvernünftigerweise in den Supermarkt gegangen und habe mir wirklich wie so ein alter Mensch diese Wärmepflaster gekauft. Und die einfach so, und vor allem, dann gibt es ja immer bei so Medikamenten, ich weiß nicht, warum das so ist, gibt es immer zwei Produkte, einmal normal und einmal intense oder special. Und ich denke mir, wer würde jemals dann die normale Version nehmen? Ich habe Schmerzen, aber jetzt auch nicht so viel. Du bist bereit, was zu kaufen, warum denn dann nicht direkt das Starke? Gib mir direkt das Krasse. Ja, gib mir immer das Krasseste. Es ist wie, als würde es Toast geben und leckeres Toast. Ja, genau. Oder so Koks und Koks light. Oder sagen sie, willst du Koks Light? Nein, ich bin so weit gegangen. Ich nehme einfach weniger. Ich kann einfach weniger nehmen. Aber das verstehe ich schon. Bei diesem Pflaster kannst du nicht sagen, so jetzt machen wir mal halb lang, so heiß. Aber die Dinger sind krass. Ich habe das unterschätzt. Ich dachte, das ist wie bei diesem Stickeralben, dieser Rubbelsticker zum Riechen, wo man sich denkt, das funktioniert gar nicht. Die Technologie... Das war dein erster Gedanke bei den Termalen. Ich dachte, damals in dem Simpsons-Album dachte ich mir, ich komme in 30 Jahren noch mal. Diese Technologie scheint noch nicht vollends entwickelt zu sein. Sind die auch heiß geworden. Wenn man lange an Lisa gerubbelt hat, ist sie heiß geworden. Jesus. Bart, nein, Erwachsener, Roma. Du bist offensichtlich verspannt. Soll ich auch noch mal dich entblockieren? Ja, entblockier mich. Ich will nicht mehr, du blockierst mich. Aber es ist tatsächlich so, und auf diesem Wärmepflaster Intens stand, Achtung, kann zu Verbrennungen führen, wo ich dachte, okay, das ist schon mal Badass, das ist das, was ich will. Das funktioniert, that's my shit. Ja, das will ich haben, und das darf man aber nicht auf der Haut anbringen, das Normale dürfte man auf der Haut anbringen, das andere nur auf Kleidung. Auf den weiten Shirts. Ja, und ich dachte mir sofort, fuck it, ich gehe all in so, ich klebe das direkt auf die Haut, ganz groß steht drauf. Wie man jetzt so einen Batman-artigen Abdruck hier? Was ist Arschgewei? Ich habe einen Arschrücken, quasi. Du hast einen, was? Ah, okay, nicht geil. Ich habe mich für das Winnie-the-Pooh-Motiv entschieden und habe jetzt quasi mein erstes Tattoo. Wie diese Toaster, diese Embleme ins Toast werden. Ja, genau. So FC Köln, bumm. Bei dir ist hinten so Winnie-Pooh hier, hast du. Wie so Kinder, indem man dann so einen Lolli gibt. Ja, und ich habe das draufgeklebt und es hat höllisch wehgetan, klar. Aber ich dachte mir, nach dem alten Prinzip, was wehtut, hilft, funktioniert das auch. Und ich glaube, ich habe mich noch nie so lächerlich gefühlt, weil ich war trotzdem den ganzen Tag kaputt und bin rumgekrebst und hatte auch noch Schmerzen von der Hitze. Ja, es war ganz, ganz furchtbar. Auch noch schwere Verbrennungen. Ja, es war lächerlich, vor allem ist es so, das wird nicht funktionieren, weil es gibt ja Ärzte dafür. Würde dieses Pflaster funktionieren, gäbe es diese Ärzte nicht so. Natürlich ist das Quatsch, aber ich bin verzweifelt.
Diese Theorie ging mir so schnell.
Naja, ich denke immer, wenn es Alternativen gibt, die teurer sind, funktioniert die billige Alternative nicht, weil sonst gäbe es die teure nicht.
Verstehst du, wie ich meine so?
Es gibt kleine Leitern und grosse Leitern und die Tatsache, dass es grosse Leitern gibt, heisst, dass du an gewisse Orte mit der kleinen nicht kommst. Aber ich kann meine kleine Leiter in Räumen verstauen, wo die grosse niemals reinpassen würde. Ja, das stimmt, aber die grosse Leiter ist auch gefährlicher. Verstehst du? Das spricht auch für meine kleine Leiter. Vor allem wir sind auch nicht mehr in der Metapher, es geht nur noch um Leiter. Jetzt geht es um fucking Leiter, weil ich weiß nicht, was du gegen meine Leiter hast. Boah, Leitern, oder? Mein Trittbrett? Ne. Ich bin, glaube ich, in meinem Leben noch nie eine Strickleiter hochgekommen. Nicht geschafft. Ich auch nicht, ich auch nicht. Nicht geschafft. Hey, komm hoch aufs Baumhaus, zwei genommen, dann gedreht, Bond, weg, vergiss es nie wieder hin. Bumm, hingefallen, ISG-Blokade, zack, Wärmepflaster, Verbrennung, tschüss. Nicht im Ansatz, wieder zurück im Mutterleib, Nabelschnur, alles kommt zurück, Hals gestorben, einfach seitdem auch nicht mehr versucht. Das war für mich so ein Ding, wo ich sage, Strickleitern und ich, das passt einfach nicht zusammen. Ja, vor allem es gibt Leitern.
Genau, das sage ich ja.
Es gibt grosse Leitern.
Ja, da war auch keine Leitern.
Ich habe von ihr Schmerzmittel verschrieben bekommen, und zwar Ibuprofen 600, 600 Milligramm Birkstoff drin.
Ich komme nach Hause und da musste ich dann Christus so einen Zettel, habe mich in der Apotheke abgegeben, die geben mir 600, ich komme nach Hause und legst zu meinen anderen Spätsmitteln Ibuprofen 400. Legst daneben und denkst, das war völlig umsonst jetzt. Wenn ich zwei von 400 nehme, ist mehr wert als diese direkt 600. Aber in Deutschland kann man 600, kriegst du nur verschrieben, sonst kann man das nicht bekommen, du kannst es nicht kaufen, sondern musst es verschrieben bekommen. Aber 400 kriegst du in dem Hunderterpack easy gekauft. Das soll mir mal jemand erklären.
Aber was ist der Rest?
Bitte?
Was ist der Rest? Also 600 Milligramm ist ja fast nichts.
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Das ist ja ein Gramm. Aber das ist eigentlich auch so eine Leiterdiskussion. Warum gibt es 400, wenn es 600 gibt?
Ja, ich weiß es nicht. Wie gesagt, ich weiß es nicht. Ja stimmt, was ist der Rest? Mehl. Es ist einfach Mehl oder der Rest ist einfach Heroin. Das ist dann eigentlich das, was hilft. So vergisst Ibuprofen-Zeug. Aber geht's jetzt wieder gut? Es geht einigermaßen so, es geht schon, es ist immer so Ups und Downs und vor allem, du bist dann so bewusst auf deinen Rücken, dass du dann auch den ganzen Tag versuchst, nur gerade zu stehen, dich nur so seitlich hinzuhängen. Und da fängt ja erst mal auf, was man alles falsch macht. Ja, und ich habe wirklich mit dem Gedanken gespielt, ob wir für heute nicht für mich so eine Chaiselon hier einfach hinstellen, weil ich mir wirklich dachte, was passiert, wenn heute Abend die Schmerzen zurückkommen und ich einfach hier darbe, kann ich mich dann einfach hier hinlegen und einfach weitermachen. Stabile Seitenlage, beleg nicht. Es geht einfach kaputt. Aber du sagst auch gerne Chaiselon. Ich sage auch sehr gerne Chaiselon. Das heisst, langer Stuhl. Das heisst, breiterer Stuhl. Leicht breiterer Stuhl. Da kann man sich drauf liegen. Weil mir geht es jetzt erstaunlich gut eigentlich, aber kann auch so Stage Health sein, so Adrenalin, und dann geht es einem wieder ganz gut. Und dann macht man Bewegungen und dann kommt man von der Bühne und dann sagt der Körper, und we shut down. Und dann klappe ich so um vor SimCity. Ich hoffe, euch geht es auch gut. Ich hoffe, euch haben unsere Becken motivierenden Dinge geholfen. Wer hat dir jetzt Rückenschmerzen? Ja, nur vorne links, oh wow, tatsächlich, nur vorne. Aber das sind schlechte Sachen. Unikonisch sagst du wirklich. Ich glaube, jeder Mensch hat Rückenschmerzen. Ja, auch wirklich nur vorne links, oh wow, tatsächlich, nur vorne. Unikonisch, so darfst du wirklich. Ich glaube, jeder Mensch hat Rückenschmerzen, oder? Weil manchmal begegnet man Leuten und denkt, okay, der ist schlecht drauf, warum? Wir haben heute darüber gesprochen, an dem Moment hat mir ein Kumpel geschrieben, ich habe jetzt auch Rückenschmerzen. Was ist da los? Ja, ich glaube, wir sind nicht dafür gemacht, auf zwei Beinen zu gehen. Sollen wir zurück auf vier Beine? Ich habe es gerade vorgemacht. Ja, nein, aber liebe Evolution, wenn das die Botschaft ist, sagt es doch einmal klar, wir werden innerhalb von zwei Jahren, können wir unsere Gesellschaft auf vier Beine nicht zurückführen. Kein Stress, wir müssen es nur wissen. So, anstatt dieser ganze Scheiß mit dem, du fährst dein Ding immer falsch, du fährst dein Fahrrad immer nur im Wheelie, so, und die Natur sagt, hol dir ein Einrad. Bin nicht gut mit Metaphern heute, muss ich das ehrlich sagen. Aber wenn man einfach das falsche Werkzeug hat. Liebe Leute, ich glaube, es ist gar nicht stehen, ich glaube, es ist sitzen. Sitzen ist das Gemeinde, weil wir sitzen alle, wir haben es gerade mit eigenen Augen gesehen. Könnt ihr euch damit identifizieren, dass man zu viel sitzt, gerade ihr. Vor allem, wir haben nicht gesagt, setzt euch nochmal aufrecht hin jetzt ins Hochheiz. Und bitte, Wieder alle ... Was ist denn in den letzten zehn Minuten passiert, dass ihr da wieder so eingeschmolzen seid? Das ist das Problem. Ihr habt jetzt mal gemerkt, wie man richtig sitzen sollte und dann wieder alles vergessen. Deswegen entwickeln wir uns auch als Menschheit nicht weiter. Nein. Weil wir sind so wie so Hunde, die sind abgelenkt. Oh, jetzt reden Sie über Leitern. Wie so ein Laborator, der durch den Raum läuft und dann sagt man, hey, und er sagt, was? Und dann vergisst er, was er machen wollte. Man denkt so, du hattest doch einen Plan, du bist doch durch den Raum gelaufen mit einem Ziel. Was ist dein Ziel? Schüttelt an dem Hund. Wo wolltest du hin, Hund? Wo? Ich wollte dich nicht aufheilen. Nein, die Nachbarn so, Schatz, er schimpft schon wieder mit dem Hund. Wo wolltest du hin, Hund? Wo? Ich wollte dich nicht aufheilen. Die Nachbarn so, Schatz, er schimpft schon wieder mit dem Hund. Und der Hund auch so, scheisse, wo wollte ich hin, ey? Zum Geiz. Er werkt auch Panik so. Fuck, fuck, ey. Ja, aber ich kenne das, wenn man so irgendwie so eine Ente sieht und die dann so kurz erschreckt und die Ente so, oh, dann, fuck, wo war ich jetzt, was war nochmal, weiß ich das, Ist das auch bei einer Entenfamilie so, wenn man die dann erschreckt, dass dann ein Küken nicht mehr weiss, dass es zu der Familie gehört? Okay, das kann sein. Und dann so, läuft es hinter dir her, nach Hause. Also du schlägst vor Ertel zwei Kükentausch, wo du einfach zwei Küken, eine reiche Entenfamilie und eine arme Entenfamilie und du tauscht die Küken und schaust einfach, was passiert. Nee, es heißt Enten erschrecken, Enten schäten oder sowas, besserer Name, sehr schlecht, aber einer hat sehr gelacht, weird. Und dann erschreckt man die und dann guckt man, wie die sich neu formieren und weiter. Ja, das finde ich gut. Und was die dann machen? Ja, und dann kannst du die nächste Folge machen, dann setzt du die vor eine Schattenwand in Küken und sagst, das ist gar nicht deine echte Mutter.
Das ist gar nicht dein echter Erpel.
Da machst du so einen Erpeltest mit Lügendetektor, da kannst du einen kompletten Sender drum bauen, dass du nur Enten konntest.
Ich dachte gerade, vielleicht geht dann eine Ente mit mir nach Hause und es ist wie Mogli, nur umgekehrt, dass ich...
Dass sie zur menschlichen Ente wird, ne ich Mogli wurde aufgezogen von Affen. Menschen. Mogli wurde aufgezogen und aus der ersten Reihe ist er selbstbewusst Menschen. Mega Story. Und da hat sich Disney gesagt, wir machen darüber einen Film. Ich glaube, du hast die billige rumänische Kopie gesehen, einfach so entführt von Menschen. Moment, wie kommt er denn da zurück? Ja, oder wie die Chinesen, die jetzt Fight Club umgedichtet haben, dass am Ende alles irgendwie gesauft wird, weil die wegen Zensur gesagt haben, nee, das kann jetzt nicht so ein Aufbruch zur Revolution. Ach so, die legen sich erst wieder hin. Es ist so, diese chinesische Version, der wird einfach von Menschen aufgesungen. Wie endet das Dschungelbuch deiner Meinung nach? Wie kommt dieser arme Junge wieder zurück in die Gesellschaft, wenn er plötzlich merkt, was passiert denn hier? Nee, und dann dachte ich mir, weil Mogli wurde ja dann von Affarte mal, von Affen auch, oder von ... Nee, von den Bären, oder nicht? Bagheera. Aber Bagheera war ein Panther. Alle rufen was anderes. Nein, einfach von so ... von ... Wölfe! Wölfe! Doch, ich meine, nämlich auch ... Im Schungelbuch gibt es doch keine Wölfe. Du meinst Tatser. Nein, Tatser, denn Mogli ist doch das gleiche. Nein. Tatser, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey! Ihr setzt euch jetzt mal alle aufrecht wieder hin. Der Richter ist in Ordnung, Ordnung! Moment, Tatsan und Mogli ist nicht das gleiche? Okay, alles klar. Dann bin ich raus, ich wünsche eine schöne Diskussion zum Thema Disney, weil ich habe keine Ahnung. Alles klar, viel Spaß mit Stefan. Also, vielen Dank und willkommen zurück bei den grossen soziökologischen Unterschieden zwischen Tarzan und Mogli. Hier links sehen wir ein grosses Bild von Mogli, das kann jetzt Florian hier mal kurz beschreiben, was wir da sehen. Ja genau, also wir sehen hier einen Jungen mit Wolfspelz. Nein, wir sehen einen Jungen mit roten Windeln. Roten was? Windeln? Roten Windeln. Ein schwarzhaariger Junge mit roten Windeln. Genau, das wollte ich sagen. Ich dachte, die rote Wölfe... Steht ja auch auf unserem Skript. Ach so, okay, genau. Er wird ein schwarzhaariger Junge mit roter Windeln. Ich hatte es anders in Erinnerung. Wimpel. Ich habe auch Wimpel erst gelesen. Rechts und rechts haben wir Tarzan, beschreibt mal Tarzan. Genau, Tarzan ist auch ein schwarzhaariger, lange schwarzhaariger Junge mit blauer Windel. Natürlich, daran kann man die gut auseinanderhalten. Lenden Shorts. Aber ist es dann so ein Ernstes, das große Krabbeln-Ding, dass zwei Filme zur gleichen Zeit rauskamen, die dasselbe Thema haben, oder ist das ... Ja, und in einem hat Phil Collins gesungen. In welchem? Tarzan. Okay, dann schau ich Tarzan an. Dann vergiss Mogli. Du kriegst mehr Geld für Tarzan. Aber welches von beiden ist das Dschungelbuch? Mogli. Okay. Weil das andere heisst Tarzan. Ach, stimmt, weil Mogli ... genau. Das, was nicht Tarzan hat. Ja, ihr seid so schlau, ihr seid so schlau, ihr habt so tolle Rücken. Aber er hat einen Punkt, gerade als wir gefragt haben, von wem wurde Mogli großgezogen, hat die Hälfte Affen gerufen, die Hälfte Balou, die andere Hälfte, es gibt sehr viele Hälften, Bagriere. Und die vierte lauteste Hälfte hier vorne, Menschen.
Menschen.
Aber ja, stimmt, weil Tarzan hat die Frau, ne? Tarzan hat Jane, Mogli hat gar nichts, Mogli hat nur Tiere.
Tarzan hat Jane.
Ja, die hat, aber wo kommt die dann her?
Oder sind die zusammen verloren gegangen, oder was?
Ist er nicht abgestürzt als im Flugzeug?
Als Kind und Jane war seine Sch- Jesus dann. What? Das wusste er nicht, von daher hat es erst. Und Phil Collins singt. Ja genau, Phil Collins. Incess. Der wusste das aber auch nicht. Aber er hat auch nicht gewusst. Ja, er hat sich auch nicht gewusst. Das kann ja alles heißen, so. Weiss er nicht. Aber Phil Collins hat alles auf Deutsch auch eingesungen. Ja. Er hat alle Songs auch auf Deutsch für die deutsche Version eingesungen. Und es klingt nicht so geil, weil es klingt so, als wäre nicht so viel Zeit in die Übersetzung geflossen. Aber es wäre so eine Google Translate und er hat so He made it work, also dass die Zeilen so einigermaßen passen. Und er singt dann Kreis des Lebens. Again. Es ist der Kreis. Das ist Lion King. Es ist,... Keine Ahnung, Leute. Er singt, mir fällt keinen Song ein. Keine Ahnung, mir fällt keinen Song ein. Keine Ahnung. Einen Song. Unter dem Meer und unter dem Meer bin ich nicht, denn ich bin im Wald und ich will mehr. So, das ist ja ein guter Song. Im Grunde kannst du jeden Song auf Tatsachen umdichten.
Das ist ja kein Problem.
Ich reiche mir nach in den Show-Notes.
Ja, wir reichen es nach.
Wir schicken jedem von euch eine Audionachricht, eine Sprachnachricht, wo wir ganz leise,
weil es ist schon spät, weil wir haben ganz lange recherchiert, 23 Uhr machen wir dann so diese Sprachnachricht, dieses wie fucking hellhörig ist deine Umgebung, dass du so leise sprechen musst, wenn es 23 Uhr ist. Weiß ich nicht, vielleicht ist es in Wien dünnere Wände. Aber ich habe einen Kumpel, der schickt mir mal Sprachnachrichten, was eh schon problematisch ist, aber immer so ganz leise geflüstert. Ja, und ich frage mich mal, wo bist du, dass du das auch löst? Habe ich noch nicht nicht gefragt, aber wahrscheinlich irgendein Ort, wo es niemand mitbekommen darf.
Aber dann schreib doch, das ist ja die Idee von Whatsapp. Ja, bei irgendeiner Geiselnahme, einfach so irgendwo hinter unserem Tisch und dann so, du, ich wollte nochmal anrufen, weil du ja meintest, dass wir Bowen gehen wollen. Und ich wollte nochmal sagen, dass ich am Samstag da keine Zeit habe. Und dann noch 20 Minuten weiter und denkst dir, was, was? Abspann. Was? Abspann. Der Abspann des Lebens. Braucht man Abspann für Sprachnachrichten? Dann sagt, Idee, Florentin Will, Schnitt, Florentin Will, Kamera, Florentin Will. Das wäre immer geil. Oh, das wäre gut. Ich würde auf meiner Beerdigung anstehen. Wer dann die gezeugt hat, oder was?
Von den Machern von, und dann die Geschwister einprüben.
Bei dir wäre, von den Machern von, weil Tobi und Bruder heisst.
Wir müssen nicht noch mehr über meine Eltern veröffentlichen. Bruder.
Ich habe schon angsterfüllte Nachrichten bekommen.
Ja, hat deine Mutter denn die Sprachnachricht gehört?
Also, wir haben ja in, so wie alle, hoffentlich waren alle dabei, in Mainz haben wir gesungen von meiner Mutter, die hatte Geburtstag, ja, okay, danke, dass jemand, einer noch an meine Mutter denkt, und wir haben alle gesungen auf die Mailbox, und ich glaube, das ist eine angemessene Art, den Geburtstag von jemandem zu feiern, indem man auf Mailboxen, 500 Leute auf die Mailbox singen, das reicht, und dann haben auch viele Leute geschrieben, so, wie hat sie denn reagiert?
Und jetzt kann ich euch sagen, sie fand es, Zitat, richtig klasse. So classic mom. Ja. Eine Antwort, die optimistisch stimmt, die mir aber auch sagt, dass sie nicht im Ansatz verstanden hat, was da passiert ist. Warum hat Florentin so viele Freunde, warum singen die, was passiert da, die versteht das ja nicht. Keine Ahnung, deswegen ist die Klasse. Ich glaube, Eltern verstehen mehr, als du jetzt denkst. Ja, weiss ich nicht. Das Einzige, was meine Mutter immer sagt, wenn ich zu Besuch bin, also ich habe jetzt wieder diese Heute-Show gesehen mit diesem Oliver Welke und der ist so, also wie der da sitzt, der ist so dick und so aufgequollenes Gesicht und der passt da. Das könntest du doch machen, Florentin. Also dieser Oliver Welke, der ist so, also ne. Also rein optisch meint deine Mutter, wärst du prädestiniert für die Heute-Show. Sie weist grob, wo du arbeitest offensichtlich. Naja, aber wirklich nur sehr grob, weil sie hat keine Ahnung, was ich mache, nichts, aber immer nur, weißt du, was ich mir gedacht habe letztens? Dieser Oliver Welke, der ist so, wie der da so bräsig sitzt, ich denke mir immer so, Mutter, schau doch diese Sendung einfach nie an, jede Woche, jedes Weihnachten, immer wenn ich da bin, immer so, nee, also der passt auch visuell da, gar nicht rein in das Studio. Bräsig, ja auch so ein Wort so, ich bin auch manchmal bräsig. Sagt man das hier? Nein, okay, noch nicht, noch nicht. Ab jetzt sagen es, jetzt sagt es bitte Bräsig. Bräsig, das ist unser Einfluss. Aber es stimmt und ich weiss auch ehrlich gesagt nicht, was ich machen würde. Ich habe überlegt, soll ich Oliver Welke mal antweeten und sagen, du, meine Mutter findet dich hässlich, kann ich deinen Job haben? Hässlich und bräsig. Ich weiss nicht, hässlich und bräsig, ich weiß nicht, ob das so ein guter Ansatz ist. Aber schreibt deine Mutter auch immer vor jeder WhatsApp-Nachricht Hallo oder Hi und dann die Nachricht und dann Liebegröße Mama? Nein, meine Mutter versteht WhatsApp nicht. Ah, okay. Gar nicht. Das hat meine Mutter immer gemacht und ich musste immer sagen, nee, es ist wie eine Konversation, die wir haben die ganze Zeit. Wir müssen es wie bei jedem Satz sagen, hi, ich wollte dich fragen, ob du die Hausaufgaben gemacht hast. Das finde ich aber spannend tatsächlich, weil, setz dich bitte, weil ich finde nämlich schon, dass man, wenn man eine Zeit lang nicht geschrieben hat, sagen wir mal so zwei Wochen oder so, dass man dann durchaus nochmal mit einem Hey einsteigen kann. Moment, du glaubst, dass man, du wolltest dich nur setzen, weil du Rücken schmerzen hast, du meinst, dass man nach zwei Wochen wieder High schreiben soll. Ich finde, auch mit einem guten Freund kann man wieder mal nach ein paar Wochen sagen, Hey du, anstatt einfach nur du. Das stimmt. Das ist ein bisschen merkwürdig, weil ich ein Jahr nicht mit meiner Mutter gesprochen habe und dann hat sie einfach wieder geschrieben, was geht.
Okay, das ist zu nah.
Also muss ich sie wieder zurück trainieren. Ja, vielen Dank an Stefan Tietze, dass er hier war als Social Media und Kommunikationsexperte.
Dankeschön, Stefan Tietze.
Ja.
Dankeschön.
Toll, gut gemacht.
Gut gemacht.
In so einer Talkshow. Gut gemacht. Hast du gut gemacht. Okay, vielen Dank. Nee, war gut, war gut, Herr Lauterbach, war gut, nee, war gut, nee, jetzt guck doch nicht so, nee, war gut Auftritt, war gut Auftritt, weiter so, weiter so. Man geht mit schlechteren Gewissen nach Hause, jetzt wird er nichts gesagt. Aber wo wir gerade bei meiner Mutter sind, ich habe Stellung bezogen. Du hast Stellung bezogen? Ich habe Stellung bezogen. Ich glaube, das ist wichtig. Und das sagt man nicht einfach so. Wenn man sagt, man hat Stellung bezogen, dann hat man Stellung bezogen. Ich habe mich zu einer Seite bekannt, und das ist manchmal wichtig im Leben, dass man Mutter oder Vater sagt, ich habe dich lieber. Genau. Du bist jetzt gerade auf Platz eins gerückt.
Bis jetzt war Vater immer auf eins, aber jetzt mit diesem Streuselkuchen Mutter auf eins. Nein, ich habe Stellung gezogen, denn meine Mutter lebt in einer Fede, in einem, ja, man könnte sagen Konflikt, in einem offenen Konflikt. Oh, bitte lass es Nachbar oder so sein. Und es ist wirklich wie eine Sitcom-Folge, denn auf dem Flur, wo meine Mutter wohnt, hängt ein Bild. Und das ist wirklich wahr, ich denke mir das nicht aus. Und immer wenn meine Mutter rausgeht, hängt das Bild schief. Sie hat eine Fede mit einem Bild. Und sie hängt das Bild wieder gerade hin. Ja. Und wenn sie wieder zurück nach Hause kommt, hängt das Bild wieder schief. Und sie rückt es wieder gerade. Und so geht das weiter. Aber es ist nicht dein Vater, der immer kichernd hinterher läuft und dann so sagt, ich habe meinen Schlüssel vergessen. Und jetzt hat meine Mutter irgendwann gesagt, so geht es nicht weiter und hat sich diese Klebeknetdinger gekauft, mit denen faule Leute Bilder an die Wand hängen. Die heißen auch so, die heissen auch im Laden Klebeknetdinger. Klebeknetdinger, die dir die Tapete ruinieren, bohr einfach, so heisst es, mach einfach ein Loch, du Depp, so heisst dieses Produkt. Und damit hat sie das Bild fest an die Wand geklebt, gerade. Kam am nächsten Tag zurück, Kleber war weg, das Bild hing schief. Was ist so besonders an diesem Bild, dass sie es nicht einfach abnimmt? Es ist nicht ihr Bild. Sie will ja auch nicht, dass es weg ist, sie will nur, dass es gerade ist. Auf dem Bild ist ein schönes, altes Landhaus. Herrlich. Und jetzt war sie so verzweifelt, weil sie geht davon aus, dass es ihre Nachbarin ist, weil sie hat mit allen anderen Nachbarn Kontakt, sie geht davon aus, dass ihre Nachbarin das immer wieder schief rückt. Motiv noch unklar, sagen wir mal so. Aber es gibt Theorien. Es gibt einige Theorien, die dürfte ich mir anhören. Nennen wir drei. Es gibt einige Theorien, und zwar ist nämlich dieses Landhaus auf dem Bild leicht perspektivisch abgebildet.
Viele von euch haben wahrscheinlich Kunst studiert oder wollten zumindest Malerei studieren, wie es in dieser Stadt sich so gehört, haben es leider nicht geschafft, viel Erfolg in der Zukunft. Diese Reaktion kann ich gar nicht einordnen. Und deswegen kann es sein, ist ihre Idee, dass sozusagen das unästhetisch aussieht, wenn das so schief hängt perspektivisch. Und deswegen wird es umgeregt. Und jetzt war sie so verzweifelt, dass sozusagen das unästhetisch aussieht, wenn das so schief hängt perspektivisch. So, und deswegen wird es umgeregt. Und jetzt war sie so verzweifelt, dass sie an mich herangetreten ist und gesagt hat, ich brauche Verstärkung. Und ich dachte mir erst, Mutter, du hast mich zu einem Pazifisten erzogen. Ich werde an diesem hässlichen Konflikt nicht teilnehmen. Das musst du mit
deiner Nachbarin austragen, das ist nicht meine Sache. Und sie meinte, wir machen jetzt folgendes, wir gehen jetzt zur Tür raus und wenn wir an dem Bild vorbeigehen, sagst du ganz laut, Mensch Mutter, dieses Bild ist aber schief. Worauf meine Mutter antwortet, ja, das will unsere Nachbarin so. Jesus fucking Christ. Und ich hatte erst mal ein paar Änderungswünsche, was das Skript angeht. Abgewährt, keine Chance, das Studio sagt nein, das verkauft sich so besser. Fade in, wir befinden uns in einem Münchner Vorortstadthaus. Und ich dachte mir, okay, ich habe noch nie eine Rolle ausgeschlagen, offensichtlich. Wir alle kennen deinen Bibieintrag, wir alle haben die Filme gesehen. Auch nicht die flachste Rolle, die ich je gespielt habe in meinem Leben. Von daher mache ich, besorgter Sohn, klar, kann ich mich reinsteigern, ich bin Method-Actor. Und so geschah es dann, dass ich Teil dieses perversen Schauspiels wurde. Aber hast du ein bisschen, okay, lass es mal reden, hast du ein bisschen mehr Shakespeare reingelegt als nötig? Ich habe versucht, ein bisschen meine eigene Stimme mit reinzulegen, wie man das ja immer versucht. Charakterschauspieler, der du bist. Aber natürlich, wie viele Theater-Schauspieler wissen werden, ist es schwer, dass sich Text natürlich anhört, wenn man ihn übertrieben laut sprechen muss, damit die Nachbarin es auch hört, weil auch die ist nicht mehr so jung. Okay. Okay. Okay, können wir... Aber gab es halt so eine kleine Probe nochmal, wie wir halt machen, wenn wir auf die Bühne kommen, nochmal so ein ... Okay, gib mir eine Sekunde, okay. Warum hängt das Bild ...
Und dann wie gehen wir raus?
Abraham, Abraham stand nah am Abhang.
Stand am Abhang?
Sprach, gar sagbar. Was will Abraham eigentlich im Abhang? Will er springen? Der saß am Abhang. Ich bin Mama. Okay, wir gehen jetzt raus. Menschen. Puh!
Mensch, Mutter!
Dieses Bild! Es hängt so schief!
Das ist, weil unsere Nachbarin das so will.
Wie merkwürdig! Und das ist wirklich... Ich habe auch genauso gespuckt, wie man das vom Theater will. Und das ist wirklich passiert und das Schlimmste ist halt, man sieht den Einschlag nicht von dem, was da gerade passiert ist.
Also was kam da jetzt an bei der Nachbarin, ist das jetzt wirklich der Punkt?
Ruhiger Sonntag, ne?
Ja, aber auch ein bisschen warm draußen.
Ja, aber gut, im Schatten.
Ja, im Schatten geht's, ja.
Morgen ist Feiertag, ne?
Ach, jetzt habe ich gar nicht genug eingekauft.
Aber wir haben noch, wir haben noch.
Ansonsten gehen wir heute Abend noch einkaufen.
Wir haben haben noch. Ansonsten gehen wir heute Abend noch einkaufen. Wir haben ja noch.
Ja, wird recht voll sein.
Tag vorm Feiertag, meine ich.
Das ist, weil unsere Nachbarin das so blieb.
Was war das? Du hast nicht wieder das Bild unserer Nachbarin entschieden.
Nein! Okay, ich tue es nie wieder!
Du hast gesagt, du weißt damit auf. Wir hatten das Problem. Wir waren bei Doktor Marquardt.
Du weisst, ich liebe das Chaos. Ich muss es sehen, wo immerhin ich gehe. Was ist denn so ein langweiliges Bild, wenn es gerade hängt? Es muss leben, es muss ihn ausbrechen aus seinem Rahmen. Ich weiss, es hat eine spannende Perspektive, aber du hast gesagt, du willst aufhören. Ich kann mein Herz nicht betrügen, nur für dich. Ich habe gesagt, ich gebe dir noch diese eine Chance, sonst lasse ich mich scheiden.
Und du hast mein Vertrauen mit Füssen getreten.
Obwohl sie die Klebe-Nagel-Dings dran gemacht hat.
Du meinst die Klebeknete von Britt? Ja, die Klebeknete von Britt, die hält nämlich echt gut.
Dass du versuchst, mich zu ändern, heisst, dass du mich nicht liebst.
Ich pack meine Sachen. Man hofft so sehr, dass er aufhört zu klatschen, weil da muss man sich noch mal verfolgen. Nein, nein, nein, bitte Leute, Leute, das können die ihm nicht antun. Aber ja, ich habe Stellung gezogen, ich bin jetzt Teil dieses Konflikts und ich weiß nicht, ob ich am Ende auf der Gewinnerseite sehe. Wie bei so einem Wikipedia-Artikel von irgendeiner Schlacht und man denkt sich, hier Trottel, warum wartet ihr auf der Verliererseite? Ja, genau. So ist es wie dumm kann man sein. So und vielleicht, ja, ich weiß es nicht, wie diese Sache ausgehen wird. Vielleicht gibt es einen Wikipedia-Artikel dazu. Ich will, dass dein Wikipedia-Artikel irgendwann so ein Kapitel hat, Kontroverse. Ja, das stimmt. Ja, das kann gut sein. Wirklich, wirklich. Es gibt kaum Kontroverse um mich herum. Ich bin wirklich sehr langweilig. Ja, die haben ja schon eine mit dem Bildkrieg. Der was? Ach so. Der was? Du hast schon Namen. Ich dachte, als ich versucht habe, die Bild-Zeitung zu stürzen,
deswegen dachte ich, als ich in meiner Hose ein Etikett von Bild gesehen habe. Ich dachte, da aufspielst du an. Kontroverse, das Bild ist schief. Ach so, ja. Aber spannend, ich bin echt, haltest du auf dem Laufenden, wie das weitergeht? Ja, du, ich glaube, ich werde nicht drum hinkommen, weil das werde ich viele Informationen bekommen. Ich bin jetzt Komplize, ich bin Komplize in der ganzen Sache. Aber ein von einem Freund, der Vater bei WhatsApp wird gerade richtig cool,
weil er fängt an, so Slang zu benutzen.
Oh, geil.
Er hat dann so geschrieben, ja, ich fahre jetzt los, irgendwie Campingplatz oder so, ich fahre jetzt los.
Hier ist ein bisschen Stau und hat irgendwie ein Kind geschrieben, ich habe den Screenshot gesehen,
fahr vorsichtig, Papa, und er hat geschrieben, sure.
Oh!
Ich dachte mir so, what, how awesome is that? Nicht ganz so cool wie safe, aber ja. Safe. Es wäre auch zwei Ebenen cool. War vorsichtig. Aber es klingt auch wie, du meinst das englische Wort. Es klingt wie in Übersetzung. Ja, finde ich gut. Aber unterstützt du sowas? Also wenn Eltern so cool sein würden, oder sagst du mir, Mama, bitte, du bist peinlich, du bist eher in der Richtung, sag doch eher sowas wie bräsig, bitte wieder, sag doch nicht, sag doch nicht schur. Ja, eigentlich, ich unterstütze es nicht, man sollte es nicht unterstützen. Ich habe so, wenn man auf diese Bühne tritt, es knarzt dann da hinten, weil ich glaube, ich habe so Angst, dass da jemand steht. Hier habe ich schon zweimal Angst gehabt, dass da jemand dann kommt hinter mir. Ich habe vorhin schon mir gedacht, nee, es ist tatsächlich, wurde uns gesagt, hier
ist eine Leiche begraben. Ah. Tatsächlich, hier unter einer dieser, das war nämlich tatsächlich ein sehr erfolgreicher Schauspieler, der hier am Wiener, hier. Ne, sag für unsere Zuschauer zu Hause, wo wir hier sind. In der Staatsoper.
Wir sind am Simmering.
Simmeringer Ring, sowas.
Simmeringer Ring.
Und der war tatsächlich einer der beliebtesten Schauspieler.
Ach, deswegen Sim City.
Genau.
Er dachte, weil es so häufig brennt, wie bei Sim City.
Ich dachte, wie Sims.
Ich dachte, es kommt von die Sims. wie zum Beispiel die Mercedes-Benz-Arena, weisst du? Oder Allianz Arena und ich dachte das ist halt von Die Sims. Oh Stefan, ey hör auf, du bist so uncool, selbst Sims kommt von Sims City, das sind die Leute, die da wohnen. Ah. Und der war so beliebt, dass die Stadt Wien und der damalige Bürgermeister, Karl der Große, Karl der Wiener, hat gesagt, ich erfülle dir einen Wunsch.
Ihr macht es mit österreichischem Akzent, das muss man mal hören.
Nein, okay, nein, nein, wir machen es nicht.
Nein, nein, nein, das haben wir uns vorgenommen, wollen wir nicht. Nee, nee, finde ich blöd von euch gerade, finde ich blöd. Was hat er gesagt? Es gibt da eine Sache, die ich mir wünschen würde. Aber nur eine Sache würde ich mir wünschen. Sie wissen, ich lieb das Theater, deswegen wäre mein einziger Wunsch, dass nachdem ich sterbe, egal wie, möchte ich auf der Bühne begraben werden. Und so geschah es. Und tatsächlich liegt seine Leiche noch immer hier. Aber er wollte auf der Bühne begraben werden. Ja, da war man sich nicht so sicher. Also man hat gesagt, wir erfüllen den Wunsch, aber nur halb. Ja, man weiss nicht, wie das im Österreichischen ist, da gibt es ja dann so hin, her gehen oder so, dann so solche Sachen und ich weiss, was, wo. Weil die, das waren nämlich Deutsche, die ihn dann begraben haben. Ja, ja, klar. Er ist ja in Deutschland gestorben, er ist in Deutschland bei einem Kulturfestival aufgetreten, hat da ein Stück gespielt. Wie hieß das Stück? Sehr moderne Stück, ein Stück hieß Nummer fünf. Ah. Einfach das fünfte Stück von Erwan Pawlacek. Ah, was du damals bei deiner Abi-Theater-AG auch gespielt hast.
Wir haben Stück vier gespielt.
Ah, aber davon konntest du noch einen Monolog auswendig.
Ja, ist korrekt, aber wenn man Stück eins bis drei nicht gesehen hat, ergibt der leider gar keine.
Das gehört jetzt hier auch nicht hin.
Und da ich leider hier an diesen trüben, leeren Augen sehe, dass niemand von euch Theater interessiert genug ist, um die gesehen zu haben, geht das leider nicht, tümmelein. Wo willst du ein bisschen gut umgedraben werden? Hast du einen Wunsch, in so einem Baum eingewachsen oder so? Ich hätte gerne, dass unter meiner Leiche so ein ganz grosser Föhn platziert wird und ich dann einfach die ganze Zeit so rumschlackere wie diese grossen Figuren. Einfach man denkt sich, okay, und dann einfach auch nicht vor einer Autohandlung, sondern einfach random irgendwie einfach so. Aber warum nicht ein gläsernes Grab, wo man dann, und man ist so in so Vaseline oder so, man kann, dann geht man über den Friedhof so und dann ist einfach, und man sieht rein. Oder so unter dem Weg oder so, weil es gibt ja so Schiffe, wo man so durch den Boden gucken kann und dann läufst du so über Leichen, finde ich auch nicht schlecht. Du, ich meine, sorry, Entschuldigung, wir brechen hier gerade zusammen an Rückenschmerzen, wir müssen uns langsam Gedankenrührer machen, was ich will sehen, wir nähern uns immer mehr dem Boden einfach schon, der Körper sagt schon, ich will da rein, ich will da rein und wir sagen, ja, okay, wo genau?
Man sagt ja das Sprichwort, der würde sich im Grabe umdrehen und ich will, dass alle Siris und Alexas der Welt quasi, wenn man nach meinem Tod über mich spricht, schlecht, dass dann so ein Mechanismus an meinem Grab, an meinem gläsernen Grab mich dreht. Dann ist es ein R riesen Event, an meinem Grab zu stehen und darauf zu warten, bis ich mich drehe wieder. Wie so ein Spanferkel, dann wirst du einfach … Aber was ist, wenn man zweimal was Schlechtes über dich sagt? Bist du dann wieder in Ausgangspositionen? Ja, ich drehe mich immer bei was Schlechtem. Das heißt, man weiss nach tausend Jahren nur, ob eine gerade Anzahl oder eine ungerade Anzahl an schlechten Dingen über dich gesagt wird.
Also ich habe mich nicht explizit gegen so einen Counter ausgesprochen.
Du, dir ist schon klar, dass es rechtlich bindend ist, wenn das jetzt das Letzte ist, was wir von dir haben, dass wir das dann wirklich umsetzen müssen und dich einfach dann auf so einen Spanfergelding aufbinden und einfach so zu unter Erde einfach die ganze Zeit. Ich wäre auch dagegen, wenn dann Leute am Grab stehen und sagen, Stefan, wer wäre der schlimmste Mensch der Welt oder was anderes ähnlich Kreatives. Ja, da fällt jetzt nichts Spezifisches ein, was du negative Eigenschaften hast. Mir fällt jetzt nichts Negatives über mich ein. Gar nichts, okay. Mir würde was einfallen, aber es ist deine Beerdigung. Okay, was würde dir zum Beispiel einfallen? Ja, ein bisschen, ein bisschen abgehoben. Und jedenfalls dann würde, würde ich mich nicht drehen. Nee, reicht jetzt, also, aber ich habe Angst, dass jemand klatscht, wenn du was Gemeines sagst. Nein, ach Quatt, dann traue ich mich nicht mehr, durch Wien zu laufen. Weil gestern war Wien so klischeehaft schön. Ich bin gestern zum Sommernachtskonzert gegangen. Und war da jemand auch gestern von euch? Ein paar waren da, die zeigen auf, das ist ein Audio-Medium, ich weiss nicht. Aber nee, das war richtig. Du kannst einfach sagen, was du willst. Es haben sehr viele aufgezeigt, alle waren da. Und es war wahnsinnig schön, es war am Schloss Schönbrunn, einfach ein Riesenschloss, wo ganz laut Klassik geblärrt hat. Und es war so, wie man sich Wien vorstellt, in so einem, weiss ich nicht, in so einem Reiseführer oder so einer Broschüre. Und da ist man einmal hier und dann das. Das war richtig schön, aber Klassik hört sich nicht so gut an, Open-Air, auf so grossen Boxen, das hat so ein bisschen so einen Blären drin. Sagt der Terrigent auch so, mir ist egal, was ihr spielt mit dieser Flöte, blast so rein, so stark du kannst. Wir haben hier ein riesiges, episches, riesige Fläche zu beföhnen, blast in dieses Saxophon, okay, Saxophon, es war ein jazziges, jazziges Orchester, wir haben dieses Stück mit Saxophon. In der Beethoven-Partitur steht nicht, dass kein Saxophon auch dabei sein darf. Ich glaube, da steht das da. Das steht nur so, was ihr wollt. Da steht nicht, bitte kein Saxophon. Nein, weil es wäre schwierig aufzuschreiben, was man alles nicht mehr. Es ist einfacher zu schreiben, wie man spielen soll. Aber kann man das in einem Orchester sagen, so einfach, gib Gas? Also, lasst man da so in diese Piccolo-Flöte mal so richtig mit voller, einfach voller Lotte rein, einfach so komplett. Aber es gibt halt auch Instrumente mit einem gewissen, mit so einem gewissen Limit. Ich glaube, so eine Harfinistin sitzt dann da und denkt dann, wie soll ich lauter spielen? Da wird der Winkel dann immer grösser und irgendwann muss man dann einfach so, komm, Claire de Lune. Gibt es E-Hafen eigentlich, elektrische Harfen, die man dann auch so umdreht und dann ... Ja, ja. E-Harpe, ja gute Frage. Und dann hat die so ... Ja, das gibt's alles klar, ja, spielst du das? Früher! Du hast früher eine E-Harfe gespielt. So, und jetzt, zu welchem Instrument bist du jetzt umgeswitcht, das cooler ist? Schlagzeug, okay. Ja, man kommt nicht ich sag wirklich cooler. Man kommt nicht gegen die Coolness von Schlagzeugen. Aber finden die Leute am Lagerfeuer E-Hafe auch cooler als deine Akustikhafe, die du vorher hattest? Vor allem, ich liebe Hafen sind ja immer so geil verziert mit so geilen barocken Kunstwerken drauf und E-Hafe stelle ich mir so vor mit so Blit, wenn es im Toten kommt. Hast du es gespielt am Lagerfeuer? Nimmt man nicht mit. Aber welche Songs spielt man auf einer E-Harfe? Also was ist so das Nothing Else Matters der E-Harfe? Angenommen, du gehst in ein E-Harfengeschäft, was würdest du mal so anzupfen, um zu gucken, ob dir was taugt? Das hat sich jetzt genau das Zeitpunkt vorangegeben, dass es Beethovent. Beethoven, okay. Aber, Beethoven. Yes. Es war eher fucking Beethoven. Stark. Es war Ludwig fucking Beethoven. Ja, finde ich gut. Ich werde es googeln heute Abend, auf jeden Fall. Wenn du bei deinem Sommernachtstraum ein wunderschön klasse Gelebnis war, dachte ich mir, ich gehe mal zu einem Event, das Wien wirklich definiert für mich, also wo man wirklich sagt so, da muss man gewesen sein. Ich war beim Sommernachtskonzert. Nein, nein, nein, also vor allem, also klar, alle jetzt hier im Raum rollen die Augen, Herr Stephan, der scheiss Tourist, so geht da auf irgendwie so diese Touristenfalle, ja, irgendwie Lichter. Touristenfalle? So und so, und ich gehe dahin, wo man wirklich sein muss als Wiener, und zwar bei den grossen Wiener Elektrotagen 2022.
Ja, ja, ich stehe für die Zukunft, ich bin für die E-Harfe da, ich sage Strom ist die Zukunft, ich mag Strom.
Wer war bei den Wiener Elektrotagen?
Na also, komm mal, erste Reihe Mitte, das ist der wienerischste Wiener, den es gibt hier, von daher Dankeschön, weil für mich war Wien immer schon die Stadt des Stroms, einfach immer Wien wie Electric City, einfach hier ist einfach so viel Volt fließt in keiner anderen Stadt, das war für mich einfach immer wichtig, deswegen war ich da und habe mich richtig genossen. Was hast du gelernt auf dem Wiener Elektrotag? Ich habe diese schwarzen Tunnel gesehen, die überall rumlagen, wo der Strom richtig durchgegangen ist.
Kabel. Ich habe mich richtig genossen. Was hast du gelernt auf dem Wiener Elektrotag? Ich habe diese schwarzen Tunnel gesehen, die überall rumlagen, wo der Strom richtig durchgegangen ist.
Kabel.
Der ist da durch, satt war der durch.
Das Kabel gesehen?
Das konntest du nicht sehen, wie schnell der da durch war.
Ich habe geguckt, so jetzt passe ich auf und dann BAP war der weg.
Nicht gesehen, fantastisch.
Ein Hyperloop in ganz, ganz klein.
Fantastisch, unglaubliche, unglaubliche Sachen.
Weißt du jetzt mehr über Strom und wie es funktioniert?
Nein, das nicht, aber meine Bewunderung ist gestiegen und das ist auch was.
Also meine Bewunderung für Strom ist gestiegen und ich bin fest davon überzeugt, dass Strom die Zukunft ist.
Nicht für diese Stadt, denn sie hat es anscheinend schon, aber für alle anderen Städte der Welt.
Aber das war für mich einfach toll, mal hier zu sein während der grosse, die Stromtage 2022. Geht dahin, es lohnt sich. Mir ist gestern, das ist so peinlich, das zu erzählen, weil mir ist so etwas Unangenehmes passiert. Weil, was sehe ich, wir hassen uns privat und verbringen uns keine ... Ich glaube, das wissen die schon, das kommt hier und da schon durch. Und gestern Abend war ich dann, musste ich dann alleine essen gehen. Oh Gott, tut mir leid, der arme Stefan muss alleine essen. Naja, wenn ich in Wien bin, dann will ich ein Wiener Schlüssel essen. Dann kannst du doch auch alleine essen. Wollte ich ein schönes Wiener Schlüssel essen und bin dann losgetigert zu so einem Wiener Schlüsselrestaurant, was empfohlen wurde, in so einer Hotelbroschüre. Und bin dann hingegangen und habe gefragt, und dann habe ich vorher auf der Website geguckt und es war alles ausgebucht, ich dachte, ich gehe trotzdem hin, bin hingegangen, hab gefragt, haben Sie einen Tisch frei und sie hat gesagt, ja, da hinten müssten eigentlich noch vier Leute kommen, aber die sind ja zu spät, warten noch fünf Minuten. Ich hab gesagt, okay, bin dann wieder rausgegangen und hab mich draußen hingestellt und sechs Minuten gewartet, weil ich dachte, ach, wie peinlich, wenn man dann sitzt und dann kommen die noch und dann schicken die einen wieder weg und dann genau am ende der fünften minute kamen so vier leute und sind hin und ich bin da hinterher gelaufen habe gesagt das waren die vier gerade und sie so ja ja aber da ist doch platz da dazwischen frei und ich habe es nicht gesehen ich habe den platz noch nicht gesehen habe gesagt ja geil weil ich wollte das wieder schlüssel das Wiener Schnitzel haben. Wie kannst du in der Situation... Na ja, Platz dazwischen. Ich dachte Tisch, Tisch, Tisch. Da sitzt die Vierergruppe, ich habe einen Tisch und da sitzt eine andere Gruppe. So, dann führt sie mich um die Ecke und es ist so ein Hochtisch, ein grosser Hochtisch. Und die Idee ist, da sitzen dann Parteien, dann ist sehr viel Platz, dann sitzt eine andere Partei. Und diese Partei war aus vier Leuten, dann war ein Platz dazwischen und dann kam eine andere Partei aus vier Leuten. Und ich wurde da hingesetzt, und zwar in Richtung Wand gucken, weil da war, und da war halt eine grosse Bank, dann war der Tisch und dann waren da verschiedene Hocker Und ich wurde genau zwischen die gesetzt, habe mich da hingesetzt und habe so eine Karte bekommen. Und beide Parteien haben kein Deutsch gesprochen und wussten nicht, was da jetzt passiert. Die dachten, wer ist der Mann, der sich da jetzt hinsetzt? Und ich glaube, die eine Familie dachte, ich gehöre zu denen und die eine Familie dachte, ich gehöre zu denen. Bist aber bei beiden nicht beliebt. Niemand redet mit dir. Und es war so unangenehm. Und ich wusste, ich dachte, ich gehe gleich. Ich habe eh schon Angst gehabt, alleine essen zu gehen, weil ich bin so ein bisschen, ja gut, wir sind beide introvertiert, haben beide keinen Bock auf sowas und Social Interactions und jegliche Awkwardness. Und ich dachte, was soll schon passieren? Komm, während man erwachsen geht, alleine essen ist okay, du bist beruflich hier, ist okay, alleine zu sein, einfach hingehen und dann passiert das.
Und ich sitze zwischen denen und super eng und der Vater von der einen Familie sass mir auch noch so gegenüber und hat mich die ganze Zeit super streng angeguckt. Und dann haben die einen bestellt und die eine Familie hat gemerkt, dass ich da nicht mitbestellt habe.
Und dann ging so in deren Sprache, ich weiss nicht, ich habe es nicht verstanden, aber die Blicke, die zu mir gingen, waren so, what's with him? Und dann hat mich aber auch kein Kellner bedient, weil die wussten, die wurden nicht gebrieft, die wussten auch nicht. Ich sass da mit meiner Karte für eine halbe Stunde und dachte mir, Jesus fucking Christ. Und dann habe ich irgendwann einfach nur, weil ich dachte, wenn ich jetzt, ich muss, dass wie eine gute Stimmung war, habe dann so gelacht zu den Kellnern und dann habe ich dann auch Sachen bekommen. Und dann wurde ich auch bedient, habe dann meinen Widerschlüssel bekommen. Und dann habe ich nur noch so viel Angst gehabt vor der Rechnung, weil, wie gesagt, niemand wurde gebrieft, niemand wusste, ich bin ja alleine. Und beide Familien haben so lange auf ihre Quittung gestarrt, um genau zu gucken, so, was hat? Jeder zählt doch mal auf, was wir alle hatten, weil das ist dieser Weirdo-Creep. Und dann ist auch die Frage, sollte man eher am Handy sein? Weil ich bin kein großer Fan von Handy am Tisch, als immer so was, weiß ich nicht, es war auch so ein gemütliches Restaurant, und dann wollte ich da jetzt nicht sitzen und allen sagen, wisst ihr, was mir hier gerade passiert, sondern dachte mir, nö, jetzt tue ich auch so, als wäre ich Teil von dieser Gruppe. Für Gespräche mit der Luft einfach so, als ob ich mit jemandem da war. Wenn man halt auf der anderen Seite gesessen hätte, hätte man zumindest in den Raum gucken können und so, aber ich lasse aber diese Wand angeguckt. Ach Gott, das sollte verboten sein, als Kellner sowas zu machen, das ist ja wirklich ein Todesurteil. Aber sie hat zu ihrer Verteidigung gesagt, du kannst dich dazwischen setzen, aber es war so ein Tonfall, wo ich dachte, könnte doch okay sein. Es war jetzt nicht, also mega weird, aber du kannst dich dazwischen setzen. So, dann hätte ich nicht, dann wäre ich nicht wirklich, dann habe ich gesagt, ha, ne, danke, ciao, aber sie hat gesagt, du kannst dich dazwischen setzen. Oh Gott, vor allem, ich weiss, ich kenne ja noch die Situation, weil ich bin dann auch jemand, der, wenn es dann sieht und einfach diesen Abgrund sieht, dann nicht sagt, ja, auf gar keinen Fall, schau.
Ja.
Sondern dann so, ja, okay, danke, danke, danke, so, nichts macht.
Aber ich habe einen kleinen Tipp für dich und alle da draußen, die vielleicht auch gerne alleine essen gehen, weil daran ist nichts falsch und man kann es gerne machen.
Und ich habe vor ein paar Monaten den genialen Gedanken gehabt, der das für mich seit immer einfach besser gemacht hat.
Und es ist gar nichts, ihr müsst gar nichts in eurem Verhalten ändern, ihr müsst nur im Kopf den Schalter umlegen, und zwar folgender Gedanke. Wenn ich alleine essen gehe, denke ich immer, die denken, ich sei Restaurantkritiker. Das habe ich auch gedacht. Weil Restaurantkritiker gehen ja immer alleine ins Restaurant. Das hat mir für zwei Minuten lang eine gute Laune gemacht, dass mir der Einfall kam, ich könnte ein cooler Restaurant. Weil Weil die, die, also ich weiß nicht, wie Restaurantkritiker arbeiten, keine Ahnung, aber die werden ja nicht in eine random Stadt gehen, sich willkürlich Leute suchen und damit in ein Restaurant gehen, sondern die gehen immer alleine. Und deswegen komme ich immer rein und sage denen immer, ah, was ist denn das Tagesmenü und versuche, denke ich mir einfach im Kopf so zu denken, ich hätte gerne einen Restauranttest. Aber ich hätte gerne Wiener Schnitzel und eine Cola. Ja, genau. Ich hätte gerne den Pinocchio-Becher, bitte.
Und Busted Right There. Wahrscheinlich ist es kein, wahrscheinlich ist der, der sich schick gemacht hat, abends um auszugehen und sich hinsetzt, alleine und sagt, ich kann Wiener Schnitzel, kein Restaurantkritiker. Aber ich glaube, das funktioniert allein im Kopf, wenn man sich das einfach nur vorstellt und dann auch mal sich so umguckt und dann einfach so auch mal beim Teller so vom Tisch irgendwie so mal ableckt oder so und dann in so ein Glas schaut und so. Auch alle anderen denken, oh crap. Ich dachte mir, warum nicht all in gehen und wirklich so eine Kladde mitnehmen und dann einfach so Sachen notieren. Und so eine Neonweste. Ja, weil für dich ist es cool, für dich ist es cool, du kannst ja auch irgendwie einen Snoopy-Comic reintun oder so und den dann lesen werden, falls du was tun willst, aber für alle anderen klingt es mega cool, Alter, Restaurantkritiker, so sehen die aus, ich dachte, die sehen anders aus, jeder hat ein ganz konkretes Bild von einem Restaurantkritiker, wir müssen nicht sagen, wie, ich glaube, wir alle wissen, wie es ist, aber so nicht. Kurz Funfact, vergessen wir danach wieder, weil es dem widerspricht, die kommen auch als Familie. Nein, kommen die nicht. Doch, doch, doch. Wo kriegen die die Fake-Familien denn her? Ja, das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Und da gibt es eine Fake-Familien-Vermittlung. Naja, manchmal haben die halt auch Familien. Und dann gehen die mit ihrer Familie. Ja, aber so ein Restaurantkritiker muss doch in einer Woche in zehn. Warum muss eine Fake-Familie sein? Naja, weil du kannst ja nicht, wenn du Restaurantkritiker bist und in Wien wohnst, nicht nur in Wiener Restaurants gehen. Du musst ja auch nach Mailand, New York, Chicago. Ja, dann sagt Guide Michelin, hier, Tickets nach Chicago. Und dann müssen deine Kinder mitreisen. Die müssen dann nach Mailand mit. Scheisse. Der so viele Termine in der blauen Gruppe im Kindergarten. Das ist Bullshit, der wollte die Knete so auseinandersetzten, die Farben sind alle durcheinander jetzt. Du kannst doch nicht einfach deine Familie zu deinem Job konstant mitnehmen. Naja, ich glaube, es ist, dass sie jeden Tag, naja, vielleicht gehen die ja mal, nimmt die die mal. Ist denn jemand Restaurantkritiker, können wir das mal in den Raum werfen? Nee, das dürfen die nicht sagen. Das dürft ihr nicht sagen.
Na ja.
Ja, ja, ja, da bewegt sich was. Testest du Restaurants? Ja. Dann bist du ein Sordtester. Der Lügendetektor, mein schlechter, zugegebenermaßen Lügendetektor. Okay, welches Restaurant hast du als letztes getestet? Das kann ich sagen. Nicht so Sidegags hier jetzt aufmachen. Okay, und welche Note, gibst du da Noten oder Zahlen oder wie machst du das? Ach, das glaubt dir doch niemand. Schrei, feil, schrei hoch, feil, sorry, da wirklich feil runter. Hey, weisst du was ich mal gerne? Nein, sorry, lügst du gerade? Ich glaube, das ist dieses Spiel am Anfang von Cashmere für Can, wo ich schon mal nicht drauf gekommen bin, wo man erraten muss, einer hat den Job wirklich und zwei lügen. Und er hat es definitiv, die Wahrheit gesagt. Meinst du? Ja, dieses Feige-Steig oben finde ich gut. Aber nur, damit wir es abgeschlossen haben. Hast du eine Fake-Familie? Oder hast du eine echte Familie? Und die nimmst du auch mit nach Mailand? Okay. Nein, die bleiben zu Hause, hat er gesagt. Nein, aber er hat sehr traurig gesagt. Du musst auch die richtige Intonation sein. Nein, wir bleiben zu Hause. Fürs Protokoll, die bleiben zu Hause. Ja, nicht nach Mailand. Dabei muss ich eine Skala 1 bis 10 aufmachen, um nach Mailand zu kommen. Vielleicht kommt man dann mit schrägen Feilen. Das ist eigentlich auch ein geiler Job, oder? Wenn du einfach in Mailand bist und sagst, Entschuldigung, ganz kurz, eine Sache, ich bin... No, no, abloh. Ja,, alema. Sie, Sie, Senor. Du hast meine Flasche umgebracht. Oh, Entschuldigung, tut mir leid. Fieses, nein, Sie können wieder gehen.
Nein, nein, nein, hören Sie mir zu, bitte hören Sie mir zu.
Jetzt spreche ich, fließe Deutsch.
Hören Sie mir zu.
Ich, hören Sie mich an.
Ich bin so wütend, ich spreche Deutsch.
Ich verstehe das.
Ich bin Restauranttester.
Und deswegen haben Sie diese Wahnwestern.
Ja, und ich muss heute Abend ein Restauranttester. Und deswegen haben Sie diese Wahnwestern. Ja, und ich muss heute Abend ein Restaurant testen. Und Sie haben da so zwei wunderbare Kinder, wie ich sehe. Könnten Sie nicht heute mit mir zusammen essen gehen und so tun, als seien Sie meine Familie? Sie sind alleine in Land gereist und wollen jetzt mit meinen Kindern essen gehen? Ja. Sie haben einen Deal. Aber auch cool, eigentlich so zu leben und sich dann immer, sich dann immer, naja, ihr kriegt einen Pinocchio-Becher schön, ja, ja, isst du gerne Eis? Red mit dem fremden Mann, red mit dem fremden Mann. Sprich mit ihm. Red mit ihm, ich hab gesagt, immer mit fremden Männern sprechen.
Oder was esst ihr gerne, was esst ihr denn gerne? Was denn?
Haribo. Haribo? Ja. Aber wenn ihr so in ein Restaurant geht oder so, was isst ihr dann gerne?
Wiener Schnitzel. Okay, in Mailand, okay, alles klar. Ja, und Sushi. Sushi? Ja. Ja, wir lieben Sushi, besonders den Salat, der ist scharf. Und das Grüne. Willst du mein Kind sein, heute Abend? Was sagt man da? Danke, ja. So eine tolle erzogene Familie, sehr schön.
Und dann gehen sie ihres Weges durch Mailand. Dann gehen sie da hin und setzt sich irgend so ein Creep neben dir und schaut dir die ganze Zeit böse an. Ich kann so nicht arbeiten, ich kann so keinen Test schreiben, dieser weirde Typ sitzt die ganze Zeit neben mir. Hast du was bestellt oder nicht oder isst der mit? Ne, ich habe es nur gehört von Freunden, von Freunden, von Freunden haben ein Restaurant und da kam dann mal eine Testfamilie hin und die haben die aber entlarvt. Aber ich weiss leider nicht wie, was sehr viel besser gewesen wäre für die Story. Und das ist eine Fake-Familie, wo Erwachsene so tun, als wären sie Kinder oder was, die dann so so auf dem Boden robben und so, ich hätte gerne den Pinocchio-Becher, kann ich was zu malen und dann mit den Fellstiften so, wie Kinder in Restaurants so sind. Vor allem, ich stelle mir das gerade so cool vor, aber ich merke, jeder kann das ja selber auch machen, jeder kann ja in ein Restaurant gehen und so tun, als wäre Tester, weil vor allem, kurzer Vorschlag, kurzer Friedensan, ich weiß nicht, ob du dasisst dahin, du kannst ja gleich antworten, aber würde es dir nicht den Job leichter machen, wenn auch sozusagen falsche Restauranttester unterwegs wären, die sozusagen so aussehen, als wären sie Restauranttester, aber keine sind, damit die Leute im Restaurant falsche Informationen kriegen, also Nieten sozusagen, so dass, wenn du sagst, die sind enthüllt, ja klar, jeder, der so wirkt wie ein Restauranttester, ist auch einer, wohingegen ich biete mich an als Niete, Niete.de, können mich buchen. Generell geil, weil du sorgst ja für ein besseres, deswegen auch mal so Fake-Blitzer aufstellen, damit Leute aufsteuern, schnell zu fahren, die dann nicht angibt, gibt es, meine ich auch. Also, ja, oder so zu tun, als sei man ein Undercover-Polizist. Ja. Und einfach, na guter Herr, was verkaufen Sie denn da, etwa Drogen? Äh, ja, wollen Sie was? Oh, das sieht so aus, als könnte man damit einen schönen Abend haben, was? Ja, also bis wir es kaufen noch nicht. Aber ist das nicht verboten, Drogen zu nehmen? Ja, muss man ja jemandem verraten, ne? Ähm, dann nehme ich eins, ja. Hat er noch keinen Verloren. Wie einer Fleischdecke bestellt. Dann hätte ich gerne 100 Gramm halb und halb. Wollen Sie Exsasy oder Molly? Dann nehme ich 200 Gramm Exsasy. Dann geben Sie mal, was ist das denn noch? Nee, ich kann Ihnen auch wie so an der Fleischwurst der Teile. Legen Sie mal. Folzene ich das so? Na, das reicht, das geht. Nehmen Sie noch einen, nehmen Sie noch einen. Und dann, was ist das Grüne da vorne? Und Sie kriegen hier ein bisschen Koks direkt auf die Hand. Ah, das ist nett. Direkt auf die Hand, zum Probieren. Ah, das ist nett. Aber das ist gut. Kam gestern gestern. Das ist ja schön. Dann geben Sie mir so eine kleine Schale davon und, ach Mensch, wenn wir da sind, packen Sie mir noch einfach 200 Gramm Heroin ein. Alles klar. Wunderbar, alles klar, dann alles zusammen bitte. Und dann zahl ich an der Kasse. Grosse Spritze. Nehmen Sie die, nehmen Sie die Grosse, ja. Geht das so oder soll ich einpacken? Das geht so, nee, das geht so.
Wollen Sie ein Tüchchen dazu?
Nee, das geht so, direkt bitte einmal.
Das macht dann 2.300 Euro.
Alles klar, gut zahl ich an der Kasse.
Dankeschön, ja, danke, wiedersehen, tschüss.
Wir haben auch sehr schöne Waffen da vorne, da kommt sie vom Wagen.
Oh, wirklich?
Toll.
Hört man so, im Hintergrund wird so eine Schießanlage.
Mal ausprobieren, einmal kostet das. Wie in so einem Gitarrenstore, wo man dann schon mal so probiert zu spielen.
Kann man in Waffenstore dann auch schiessen?
Ich war selten in Waffenstores.
Ich weiss nicht, als wir in New York waren, haben wir gegoogelt.
Shooting Ranch.
Can you go to America as a German and shoot some guns?
Und Google hat überraschend rhetorisch gewandt gesagt, no, you cannot, you definitely cannot. You cannot. Das You war gross geschrieben. You can't. Smug, smug Google. Aber auch immer so diese Probierdinger, oder? Ich muss einmal eins mal sagen über Österreich und über Wien im Speziellen. Ich finde, ihr habt eine ganz tolle supermarktkultur da nicht tipptopp sind alle anders offensichtlich da kommt gar gut nee nee nee man muss auch komplimente bescheiden auch einfach mal ablehnen können das gehört auch dazu einfach als stadt zu sagen ja ja aber dann sieht Man sieht man, dass er in einer sehr coolen Stadt wohnt, wenn er sagt, nee, das nicht. Auch einfach mal sagen so, nee, ich habe keine schönen Augen. Eigentlich habe ich keine schönen Augen. Nee, es ist mega schön hier, mega sauber, keine Kriminalität, wir haben mega geile Konzerte. Ja, aber nein, aber der Billa ist doch fantastisch. Im Ernst, ich war doch heute und da gab es kostenlose Probierdinger. Ja, er kam hier rein und hat gesagt, Biller ist so fantastisch. Ich wusste nicht genau, was es ist. Supermarkt kommt heraus. Ich glaube, es ist auch nur so, weil in Deutschland gibt es den Biller mit E-R. B-I-L-L-E-R, Biller, die Möbelerlebniswelt. Und das ist nämlich die Möbel-Erlebniswelt und deswegen komme ich nach ...
Sing die Strophe.
Komm ich.
Du willst dir neue Möbel bestellen, dann komm doch vorbei zum Billa.
In Bottrop-Kichelm.
In Bottrop-Kichelm und nicht in Österreich.
Und du kommst hier und denkst dir, ah, what the fuck, die haben an jeder Ecke ein Billa?
Wie viele Möbel kann man denn gebrauchen?
Was ist denn hier auch vor allem so kleine Läden, wo man einfach mal so kurz reinsnackt und dann einfach so eine Kommode mitnimmt? Nee, wir haben diese Kommode und diesen Stuhl. Okay, nämlich beide. Okay, und dann direkt das Clothes-Zild. Bankrott, ja, wir sind durch, wie gesagt. Ich war faszinierter, ich dachte mir, wie viel Möbel braucht eine Stadt, einfach zu jeder Zeit. Ja, für ihre riesenhohen Deck, Altbaudecken. Ja, genau, die müssen ja auch gefüllt werden, die Wolkenkratzer. Ja, wir stapeln, wir stapeln Tische übereinander. Und da habe ich gemerkt, nein, es ist ja gar kein Möbelhaus. Und dann war ich wahrscheinlich aus dieser Verwirrung her so froh, dass es ein toller Laden ist. Ich mag den gern, wenn ihr das nicht zu schätzen wisst, was ihr habt. So ein Problem, man merkt erst, was man hat, wenn es weg ist. So geht es dann nicht. Was willst du jetzt machen? Ja, wenn die eines Tages weg sind, dann heißt es, oh Gott, wo ist der Billa hin? Machst du so einen Elon Musk für den Move? Nur mit Billa? Kaufst Billa auch? Ich aufkaufe und schließe, nur um euch zu zeigen, was ihr verpasst, wenn ihr es nicht habt. Ist das so böse bist du?
Ja.
Du bist so ein Disney-Villain.
Aber ist Villa eher sowas wie Rewe oder eher sowas wie Lidl?
Ja, es ist das eben das Ding.
Das belegt so einen gewissen Sweetspot, den gibt es in Deutschland nicht.
Du hast dann so Penny Netto, die ganz billigen, dann die anderen Discounter und Villa ist irgendwie so. so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so,ile liegen genau perfekt. So ist Billa einfach. Nicht gesponsert an der Stelle, aber hätte ich es.
Leider.
Warum sind unsere Werbungen...
Wahrscheinlich gibt es einen super krassen Biller-Skandal gerade, den jeder hier weiss, nur ich nicht.
Einfach so, ja, da wurde Koks in den Bananen gefunden, einfach so offensichtlich und alle so, wir gehen da nicht mehr hin oder jetzt erst recht, keine Ahnung.
Große Antisemiten, Familie Biller.
Na gut, du kennst dich besser mit der Stadt Wien aus als ich.
Ich weiß nicht, ne, ich kenne, ne, ich fände nur sehr laut, aber es war auch so kurz vor einer Massenpanik, ehrlich gesagt, da sind sehr viele Leute zu diesem Sommernachtskonzert. Ich hätte es nicht lustig gefunden, wenn Sommernachtskonzert, aber es klingt so friedlich. Und dann plötzlich waren da halt so, ich glaube, es waren so um die hunderttausend Wienerinnen und Wiener dann da hingelatscht. Und ich war super spät dran und war in so einer Gruppe, die dann so ganz enge Wege langgelaufen sind, super viele noch, viel zu viele, weil der Platz war auch immer schon voll und es war irgendwie ein bisschen sketchy, weil dann wurde es immer enger mit so ein bisschen Metallzäunen, die so Massen kontrollieren sollen, man hat sich gefühlt wie so ein Rind, was so da reingeschoben wurde und dann war man dann so irgendwann und dann haben Leute angefangen, die Dinger wegzumachen und haben Abkürzungen genommen und die Ordner waren so Jesus fucking Christ. Wir ziehen uns zurück, drehen so um auf Close und einfach so ein Wissen raus. Und es war so, und haben die so angefangen zu schreien, so, nein, ihr müsst da lang gehen, ihr müsst da lang gehen und alle so, wir sind eine Masse. Hat einer, ein einziger hat gesagt, nee, wir sind eine Masse, also hat er nicht gesagt, aber er hat sich so benommen. Ich bin eine Masse, ja. Und ich denke mir so, wenn jetzt alle stehen bleiben würden, du bist keine Masse, aber alle sind dann da lang gelaufen und es war nicht so geil organisiert an der Stelle, Shoutout Stadt Wien, weil ein bisschen problematisch. Und ich dachte, da, okay, da, okay, weil das war... Okay, ihr mögt es anscheinend eher kritisiert zu werden, habe ich das Gefühl. Es ist ein sehr bescheidenes, feedbackoffenes Publikum, weil die sagen so, nein, unsere Stadt ist nicht perfekt. Nein, wir arbeiten gemeinsam dran. Wir versuchen jeden Tag ein bisschen besser zu werden. Wir fangen mal bei den Kellnern an, die Leute irgendwie weird hinsetzen. Das ist so ein Gegenteil, zu so einer shitty deutschen Stadt, wo man dann sagt, wie man es kritisiert und die alle sagen, sind mega auch Fälle und sagen, buuuuuh, und hier sagt man was und alle. Wir gehen da gemeinsam rum. Wir sind Wienerinnen und Wiener, wir entspannen uns und arbeiten jetzt gemeinsam an dem Problem, um es besser zu machen.
Ja, finde ich gut, die applaudieren und sagen, ja, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass der Biller-Chef Antisemit ist, ist recht hoch in unserer Stadt.
Und die ist wahrscheinlich so, statistisch gesehen, die wissen einfach, wo sie stehen. Und das finden wir gut. Dafür unterstützen wir euch auch.
Ja, es war ein bisschen problematisch. Und ich dachte, dieses Klassik-Publikum sollte nicht das Publikum sein, was sich so benimmt.
Nee.
Aber die sind über die Dinger gesprungen und so. Aber die spielen auch wild manchmal, oder? Also ich kann mich da auch nicht zurückhalten. Wilhelm Tell. Und ich im Mosh-Bit einfach, ich will da auch einfach Bock haben. Also wenn der sagt, dann, Alter, mit einem fucking Rücken, das kannst du nicht machen. äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, ä Schietze vom Flur im Team. Vielen Dankeschön. Vielen, vielen Dank euch. Chauvin, macht's gut.
Dankeschön.
Und wir heben ab, macht's gut.
Heben ab.
Nice.
Macht's gut.
Chauvin. Vielen Dank. Und auf Lotto-Bayern.de. Lotto-Bayern, nimm dein Glück in die Hand.